[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain an american comedy heist film
called the perfect score
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
kyle is a normal high school senior
aiming to get into cornell university's
architecture program he knows exactly
what he wants in life but the s.a.t is
standing in between him and his dreams
in the opening scene he is in the
examination hall looking through the
answer sheet that is telling him he is
just an average guy after the examiner
asks them to stop writing kyle looks
around and locks eyes with anna she has
a 4.0 gpa and is the second highest
ranking student of the school what makes
it surprising is that her answer sheet
is completely blank in the background it
is narrated that students might be good
at different things some are better at
singing and others at sports but
according to the sat everyone has to
pass a standardized examination that
will determine their future the narrator
thinks it is unfair so he calls the sats
a suck ass test
got him the results are published and
kyle scores 10 20 as opposed to the
minimum 1430 that he needs to get into
his preferred college he complains to
the principal about the absurd method
that the sat uses to test the students
according to kyle math equations and
complicated social scenarios are not the
way to determine if a student should get
to go to their dream college the
principal receives hundreds of students
after every test complaining about how
unfair it is but all of them have one
thing in common their score is less than
what they need for him kyle is just one
of many so he dismisses the conversation
after giving him the same lousy advice
that he delivers to every student then
we are introduced to maddie kyle's dumb
best friend and his right hand man he
has an average gpa of 2.3 and is not so
good at studying maddie's girlfriend
sandy is a freshman at maryland college
so his only goal in life is to join
maryland and hook up with her one more
time kyle tells him that he lied to his
parents about scoring 14 30. the poor
fellows even bought him a cake to
congratulate him his older brother larry
is a bigger idiot than maddie he lives
on top of his parents garage that he
claims is a different house because it
has a separate phone line larry
accidentally blows the zero from the
candles and jokes about how he got a 143
sat score back in his day later the
friends go to the educational testing
service center commonly known as ets to
complain about the unfair system however
the receptionist stops them because many
students like them come to complain
about their s.a.t scores every day as
they are asked to go away a girl proudly
walks into the building she is the talk
of the town and the dream of every high
school guy francesca she walks into the
building like she owns it which is
untrue because her father is the one
that owns it that evening kyle and
maddie drink while thinking of a way to
ace the next test maddie calls his
girlfriend sandy but a man picks up her
phone the call ends in only a second but
maddie registers that she is cheating on
him he blames the sats and suggests they
steal the answers for the next test kyle
laughs it off at first but starts to
take the idea into consideration the
next time they meet he asks maddie if
they were to borrow the answer sheets
from ets how would they go about it
maddie suggests they ask francesca for
help since she can enter the ets
headquarters anytime she wants moreover
she is an adrenaline junkie and will do
anything to have fun a heist is right up
her alley so the guys are positive she
will join them when she is briefed about
the plan she immediately agrees then we
are introduced to a star basketball
player desmond he plans to join st
john's university and play for their
team even the dean is happy to have him
however he has to take the sats and
score at least 900 to get into college
desmond is excellent at math but that
would still not be enough for him to
make it kyle and maddie are in the
school's bathroom when kyle reveals that
he told the school topper anna about
their plan he has a crush on her but
refuses to admit it maddie freaks out
because she is one of the nerds who will
probably tell the police but kyle
assures him they are fine because she
refused to be part of their plan anyway
the two had thought they were alone in
the bathroom and are surprised when the
school junkie roy appears in one of the
stalls kyle and maddie hope that he is
too high to understand what they said
but the guy is used to being highly
alert even when high at last they have
to reluctantly include him in the plan
at night anna returns home to see that
her parents have called a professor from
brown to help her get into university
she is tired of them pushing her to do
better because she doesn't even want to
go to an ivy league university in the
first place since she zoned out in the
last sat they have been pressuring her
more than ever the next morning
francesca kyle maddie and roy go to the
ets headquarters and devise a plan for a
simple heist francesca provides them
with the uniforms from the mail room and
makes them enter the ets floor without
any problem they had asked roy to stay
outside but he somehow enters the
building on his own and includes himself
in the plan
then the group separates and goes around
the office trying to figure out which
cabin has the sat answer sheet meanwhile
in the school library desmond meets anna
and asks her to help him to prepare for
the s.a.t however anna herself is
stressed about the test and is scared
she will mess up again she thinks of
joining kyle on his heist and also tells
desmond about the plan hoping it would
help him back in the headquarters a
woman finds roy snooping through her
office she is about to report him but he
uses his poor flirting skills to make
her stop even though his pickup lines
are lame she seems to enjoy them in the
other room an office worker calls kyle
and hands him the s.a.t question sheet
kyle is left stunned but it turns out
that the man mistook him for a worker in
the copy room he asks kyle to print two
copies of the paper and hand them back
kyle happily goes to the copy room but
accidentally shreds the paper instead of
copying it they are back to square one
because of his stupidity following that
anna meets kyle and asks to be included
in the plan along with desmond kyle had
lost hope but now that anna wants to be
part of the plan he thinks of another
way to acquire the paper he collects the
blueprint of the building from francesca
and asks her to get all the security
codes anna spies on headquarters
security guard and finds out the routine
of the rounds he takes every night then
they decide to meet at kyle's brother's
place to go over the plan one last time
while francesca is coding something roy
helps her proving that he is a technical
genius kyle keeps it in mind because
they might need his help in case of an
emergency in other words in case they
need to do a stupid 90s hacker scene
then he briefs them on the plan although
it is a little shaky and success isn't
guaranteed the group agrees to help him
the next day roy desmond and anna stay
outside the ets headquarters to keep an
eye on the building's guard meanwhile
kyle and maddie enter the building and
wait until the top floor is cleared when
all the employees go home francesca
distracts the security guard giving the
two an opportunity to run to the roof
from there they use a rope to enter the
topmost floor and get to the room where
the papers were supposed to be kept
however it turns out that the floor has
been renovated since the blueprint was
made and they do not know where the
papers are they refuse to return
empty-handed and start brainstorming
other ideas kyle remembers that the man
who ordered them to print the papers
also has a copy on his desk they go to
his office and start looking around with
their flashlights just then the security
guard steps outside to smoke the flashes
of their lights are clearly visible from
the guard's view so anna quickly calls
the group to alert them they turn the
lights off seconds before the guard sees
them after that they finally find the
room they are looking for but the answer
sheets are nowhere to be found as a last
resort they try to open the computer but
it requires a password they call the
technical genius roy for help but they
will have to distract the guard before
letting him in this time maddie comes up
with a plan and calls his friend to
deliver flowers and alcohol to the
guard's name when the guard is busy
receiving the gifts roy runs inside
along with him anna and desmond also
come thinking that they might be of help
then roy predicts the password using a
picture on the table the group finally
gets their hands on the question paper
but to print it out they will need three
more passwords they lose all hope and
are about to return but kyle refuses to
give up he says that they can solve the
answers in time before the guard comes
for a routine round everyone else laughs
at him because if they could answer the
questions they wouldn't have to be there
in the first place he reads the first
question out loud and anna answers it
instantly she couldn't answer the
questions in a classroom because of
stress but when she is with them she can
easily solve the paper desmond is also
excellent at math so he and roy solve
the math portion of the test while anna
and kyle solve the verbal lastly
francesca and maddie are told to watch
the lobby while waiting they get into a
conversation about maddie's girlfriend
sandy who doesn't call him anymore
francesca tells him that it is over and
asks him to get over her but maddie gets
irritated by the comment suddenly she
kisses him and claims that he would be a
good boyfriend to whoever he loves a
while later they get done with the
questions and finally get ready to leave
roy tries to climb up first but the
others pull him down noticing that he
has stolen supplies from the office
desmond makes him put them back in their
places while the others continue
climbing up anna and kyle easily make it
to the top but the security guard comes
for the rounds before the others can
escape desmond maddie and roy are in the
safe zone but francesca is about to be
caught at that moment maddie decides to
come in front of the guard to save her
while the others climb to the rooftop he
surrenders and is arrested
well no one said simpen was easy
the next morning francesca steals money
from her father and bails maddie out
they reunite and kiss maddie doesn't
want to take the sats anymore because he
thinks he's better off not going to
college he wants to take a year off to
find out what he wants to be in life
anna is also a different person from who
she was yesterday she stands up to her
mother for the first time and declares
that she isn't going to brown following
that the group gathers and kyle hands
them the answers however anna refuses to
take them because she wants to go to
europe for college desmond and roy also
do not want it because roy wants to
start creating online games and desmond
has gained confidence after solving the
questions during the heist francesca who
already had a perfect sat score has no
use for the answers and maddie is also
not taking the test at last kyle too
refuses to use them because they are of
no use now roy hands them to his junky
friends who ace their test because of it
a few months later desmond takes the
retest and gets into his desired
university maddie starts to audition for
acting roles while francesca sells her
first novel kyle also does fine on his
retest although he doesn't get into his
preferred college he still dreams of
being an architect anna on the other
hand moves to europe for further studies
she starts dating kyle and frequently
returns to new york to meet him lastly
roy sells a hit online game making
millions of dollars in the ending scene
we see him living his best life
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching